bueno vuelvo al tema que tocó que irá ya
de los extranjeros me gustaría saber
aunque no veo mucho con estas luces hay
algunas personas aquí que nacieron en
punta cana-bávaro y verón
no muchas verdad entonces confirma mi
sospecha
pienso que casi la mayoría somos o bien
de otras partes de la isla o del
extranjero
qué significa esto que estamos aquí
solos con la pareja o con la familia más
cercana el mini núcleo y el resto de los
familiares los tenemos lejos si viven en
la isla pues pueden llegar ahí en coche
sino al resto de nosotros pues nos toca
el avión
para mantener contacto con ellos
dependemos
también mucho de lo de los medios de
comunicación gracias a dios existe
whatsapp vídeo y skype
y nos es más fácil
yo soy me llaman oficialmente una
expatriada ex fuera de mi patria en mi
caso de alemania y hay 230 millones
expatriados en todas las esquinas del
mundo
somos estudiantes pensionistas
profesionales y las familias
profesionales
muchas veces llegando a los otros
destinos los acompañantes no nos dan los
permisos de trabajo y llegamos ahí como
le llaman en inglés try links pause a
ver la mayoría somos mujeres pero yo he
conocido también hombres que han llevado
esta labor y lo han llevaron muy bien
los niños momentito aquí vamos
esta es la familia en el extranjero aquí
vienen los niños que tienen un nombre un
poquito más bonito que son verticales y
kids porque no viven ni en la cultura de
la mamá ni el papá
si no crecen en una o varias terceras
culturas
yo he dado como ha dicho que da muchas
vueltas en el mundo y es estar en un
total de cuatro continentes 8 países 14
sitios y hecho un total de 24 mudanzas
que este que está un poquito extremo no
lo recomiendo tampoco
y antes de cada cambio mi esposo empieza
siempre de la manera siguiente y espero
que cambio un día porque siempre viene
con estas palabras que son siéntate mi
amor escúchame
después de todas las explicaciones de a
dónde vamos cuándo va a ser pues me
entra el pánico temporal me pongo a
llorar
trato de respirar no lo logro y me cruza
por la mente a dónde vamos cómo lo voy a
hacer y la típica porque yo
me siento al final y respiro hondo y me
preguntó a ver quiero yo hacer este
cambio no mi esposo
pero yo
y con esta pregunta evitó un poquito en
la expresión esta de trading spies que
la esposa que sigue al esposo si tomo la
decisión consciente me siento como la
esposa que va a su lado
por otra parte me pregunto también
conscientemente si quiero hacerlo porque
como a todos nos gusta echar la culpa a
otra persona a mí también sobre todo en
los primeros meses cuando llego al nuevo
destino y las cosas no van como tendrían
que ser entonces mi esposo es el
culpable de todo
preguntándome pues ya me puedo echar la
culpa a mí
estoy segura que se reconocen aquí
somos las mujeres el eje eje de la
familia sobre todo las expatriadas y los
expatriados
y hoy en día me gustaría incluir a
ustedes como expatriadas nacionales que
se han mudado también aquí a esta parte
de la república dominicana porque
hacemos posible este cambio somos
nosotros las que organizamos
planificamos llevamos a cabo todo esta
gran montaña que que es una mudanza
desmontamos la casa en un país y la
llevamos a otro siempre con el tiempo de
atrás y los niños alrededor de nosotras
nuestra familia y los amigos no
entienden cien por cien me imagino que
saben que digo en que estamos y
escuchamos los típicos y como me
gustaría estar en tu lugar
y yo también me quiero cambiar y quiero
llegar hasta el país
la verdad que no te entiendo tienes que
estar solamente bendecida te tienes que
sentir así y este es el momento cuando
yo quito la pérdida de mi foto de perfil
a ver tengo claro que sí que estoy
bendecida y afortunada de haber a doctor
a estas vueltas del mundo quedaron y doy
gases a dios todas las mañanas pero
desgraciadamente y honestamente se me
olvida un poco cuando llego al nuevo
destino y me encuentran me encuentro
con las curvas de adaptación que me
tocan
el ajuste de los expatriados
las primeras fases es muy bonita la luna
de miel
les cuento como yo lo siento llegó todo
me parece fenomenal la gente la comida
los amigos el tiempo excelente no podía
ser mejor llevo mis gafas de colores
rosa
y no hay nada que me molesta
me siento además como la turista interna
disfrutando de toro
pero desgraciadamente
viene el choque inicial cultural en esta
fase me doy cuenta que no todo era tan
bonito que hay cosas grandes y pequeñas
que me molestan
y además la mudanza no ha llegado como
estaba planificado
no puedo avanzar nada y me empiezo a
frustrar
pero me salva el ajuste superficial
empezará a conocer a gente me hago la
idea del lugar he descubierto un poquito
encontrar dónde se come mejor mofongo
aquí y me siento bastante adaptada
esta fase no tarda mucho porque llegamos
a la con el valle más profundo que es el
choque cultural
ahí
hay nada que hacer vivo con la caja de
kleenex al lado porque estoy fatal no me
gusta nada me molesta todo en sí que ha
sacado todas las cajas pero me dado
cuenta que van a estas navidades este
perdió la caja del árbol de navidad
tampoco encuentro los dulces navideños
alemanes en los súpers
y de toda esta gente que he conocido
todavía pues nadie se ha hecho amigo
estoy lista de tirar la toalla o por lo
menos de volver para una por unas
semanas a mi país
me salva la recuperación
ya me da cuenta que la que se tiene que
acostumbrar soy yo que no son los otros
si quiero sobrevivir en este nuevo
destino pues me tengo que acoplar y
hacerme la idea de
vámonos adelante
y la última fase pues es la que en la
cual ahora estoy es la mejor que es la
integración ya casi me siento dominicana
puedo hacer un buen sancocho
a la casa has hecho un hogar me gusta
pasar tiempo ahí tengo mi rutina de yoga
por la mañana después de la escuela de
juanillo para ayudar por la tarde juego
pádel y he retomado mi famoso estudio de
psicología online ya estoy bien y estoy
súper tranquila
estaba pensando qué podíamos hacer para
que éstas
este ajuste que es una auténtica montaña
rusa y que toca siempre puede ser un
poquito más fácil y me dado cuenta que
para mí son algunos pasos que me ayudan
algo para hacerlo mejor
primero es
o sea como un camaleón cambiarme de
color según el país adapto agrop
a ver adaptándome lo más rápido que
pueda
tener y crear una rutina lo antes
posible lo mejor es he visto yo en la
luna de miel porque en esta fase tengo
mucha energía estoy muy positiva
entonces si logro de hacer una rutina en
esta fase muy bien
la siguiente le dejo aquí el chiste le
dan in adquirido para para los
extranjeros son personas demasiado
perezosas para aprender nuestro idioma
así que se inventaron uno propio
pues yo siento la necesidad de aprender
el idioma y como quiera dicho hablo
varios no tienen que llegar a este
extremo pero sí me parece importante
tener por lo menos una base para poder
tener una conversación con la gente con
la cual te encuentran que siempre va
bien y nos abre muchas puertas
la siguiente sería encontrar un balance
entre mantener el contacto con los
amigos y familiares que hemos dejado
detrás y con la familia y los amigos que
tenemos en el presente porque si pasamos
todo el rato al teléfono o en las redes
sociales
estamos en el pasado no estamos en el
presente presente y lo último sería pues
la ayuda y ha dicho que fue momento aquí
voy a la escuela déjame juanillo y lo he
hecho siempre así
por ejemplo en vivimos en bali en
indonesia
y ahí asistía en un orfanato de niños
sólo muros al principio solamente
haciendo actividades extracurriculares
como pintar más de manualidades y
después ayuda crea un programa para los
niños que salían del orfanato que con 17
años ya no podían continuar ahí y
brindarles así una idea para su futuro
también conseguimos alianzas con hoteles
que les ofrecían puestos de trabajo y
esto ayuda muchísimo
en mallorca en españa estuve ayudando
justamente en una causa que mencionaba
en teherán en su toque en inglés antes
en ayudé en rana que es red en ayuda de
niños abusados montamos organizamos
bazares y un gran baile anual todo para
recaudar fondos para la prevención del
abuso infantil
cómo hacer esto de
aquí un dicho de nelson mandela
cómo podemos hacer eso de encontrar
dónde ayudar
y muchas veces cuando llegamos a un
sitio nuevo no lo sabemos
pues hay unos pasos que les pueden
ayudar
encontrar su motivación que les motiva
a mí me motivan muchísimo los niños
recuerdo un momento en el cual vivimos
en yakarta en la capital de indonesia y
todos los días pasé por un área de
basura que era un muro grande con
favelas alrededor unas montañas de
basura en el medio y un día recogiendo
mi hija de kirchner pasé por ahí y vi a
niños jugando en estas montañas me
impactó y quería pararme en este momento
pero no lo hice porque pensaba que van a
pensar de una rubia saliendo encontrado
ahí y me meto ahí en su en su esquina y
otro sabía que mi esposo no voy a estar
al favor por temas de seguridad
pero la semana cuando viví la misma
situación los niños jugando ahí sí me
pare tomé mi hija jessica de 3 años y
nos lanzamos nos acercamos en seguir a
los niños estaban todo nuestro rededor
los adultos con un poquito más de
distancia pero hablamos con ellos
preguntamos en qué podíamos ayudar y nos
trajeron con comida hicimos una lista y
a partir de este día pues todos los
miércoles después de haber recogido a
jessica pasé con ella por ahí yo
entregando la comida y ella jugando con
los niños la pregunta es que les motiva
el segundo paso es
preguntarse que quieren invertir
dinero tiempo o las dos cosas yo soy la
que va gente en que dicen manos a la
obra a mí me encanta eso pero otras
personas no prefieren dar dinero yo
pienso que cualquier ayuda es válida y
sirven
y por último sería
mi sugerencia buscarse algo alrededor de
uno para que los pretextos de aya esta
red no llego y está un poquito lejos no
sirven tiene que ser algo cercano y
fácil también a mí me gusta mucho
involucrar a mi familia mi esposo me
acompaña en las carreras quedan aquí por
ejemplo cerca de beneficios
había una de beneficio de autismo sin
fronteras y otras pues vamos por ahí
apoyando con lo poco que podemos dar ahí
en las entradas pero si vamos muchos
pues se acumula todo y mi hija jessica
como la lleve desde pequeña a todos los
lados ella también está haciendo un gran
labor ya con sus 18 años
nos podrá ayudar también ayudar a los
otros de encontrar el famoso sentido de
la vida porque muchas veces sobre todo
cuando llegamos a nuevos lugares a
nuevos países estamos tan metidos en
nuestro mundo en nuestros problemas que
que pensamos que de sentido estaba por
este lado y al final estaba por ahí
pues seamos parte activa en este mundo
hagamos lo que dice el tema de hoy que
eso venga presentándose
para que cuando la vida venga y nos diga
siéntate mi amor escúchame
podemos decir sí con mucha confianza
muchas gracias